[Music]
um Kelly you found this
yes I did the 10 most common sources of
conflict in relationships
um so I went through this and
I'm going to kind of do it out of order
and I ended up focusing on a few things
other than those 10 things so study of
2600 married couples from Britain China
Russia turkey and the US found the most
common sources of conflict drum roll
please huge surprise here
not really division of labor inside the
home finances raising children and sex
and women were more likely to report
problems than men
no way no way
man this these are our research dollars
hard at work America all right I want to
talk about these five for a minute
before I get to
I'll run through the other stuff but let
me get to these five
division of labor I have man I'm gonna
get myself in trouble here and that's
fine I feel like there's some truth
telling that needs to happen here
this is often regulated along two
distinct lines
and one is discussed a lot and the other
one isn't and I've never heard it
discussed anywhere other than in quiet
Whispers
with a group of guys playing poker or
just going for walks in the woods
because they don't know why their wives
don't like them so much
here's number one
we talk about this and we've got to talk
about it more
women's roles at home even with the vast
acceleration of women into the workforce
I think this weekend I was at 7 out of
ten college graduates or women I mean
the the scales have tipped so far the
other way
women are in the workforce they're in
higher education they are
um they're closing the the pay Gap
and women still take on the Lion's Share
of household chores
and yes
I think it's because men don't see this
as quote unquote their job and I know
it's going to get me in trouble but
sometimes women do see it as quote
unquote their job and there's this
disconnect and men go home and they prop
their feet up and they then wonder where
their dinner magically is and they
wonder how these diapers are magically
getting changed that exists the research
does if I'm being honest it says that
Gap is closing but it is still not
close to being closed
and
the other line
is often one partner in a romantic
relationship determines the Benchmark
for household chores what needs to be
done around here
and then criticizes or complains the
others not agreed upon standard
and we don't talk about that enough
that's usually talked in hushed Whispers
for instance honest she's my house for
example because my wife doesn't listen
to this show so it's okay
I could do just fine
with the dishes being done two or three
times a week maybe once a week maybe
once every other week
and for my wife they need to be done
every day
seven days a week
and so there's been conflict over time
in our marriage because she says you
don't help out around here
and I'm looking around suggesting
there's no help needed those dishes will
be fine there's like seven plates and
four cups in the dishwasher I mean in
the sink
nothing's on fire there's more in the
cabinet
and for her that is one of the things
that needs to be done before the day is
over and so
I would challenge
the notion I'm not helping around the
house
I would challenge that with this idea
that we have not sat down and said hey
here's what makes you feel whole in this
house here's what makes me feel hold in
this house let's get there and then from
there if I don't do what we agreed upon
now we got a problem
Kelly
you're married am I off here oh no way I
mean that you just a hundred percent
described my marriage of oh no it's
gonna be trouble my husband's saying but
the bathroom is clean it means me saying
but it wasn't wiped down this weekend
and he'll be like but it's clean
and so you go to your your girlfriends
you know hanging out and she's like
Robert never cleans the bathroom I gotta
go clean it and he is staring off into
the stars in the in the front yard in
his underwear just like what am I doing
wrong I don't understand yeah the
neighbors don't like us very much so
maybe that explains why
um but yeah because it's like but to him
it's like fine look at it there's
nothing the issue here isn't a reported
he's not helping on the house it's
really we haven't sat down and
established what does clean look like
and you giving a little bit and being
like okay it doesn't have to be
sandblasted every other Saturday and him
you're like yes every Saturday not every
other thank you very much
and him realizing that just because
there's no dirty underwear on the floor
that doesn't mean clean and I remember
my mom told me there's a difference
between picked up and clean I get that
that's the division of labor
this is the division of labor
conversation okay so what we did and
just hire someone
oh gosh don't even get me going there
hey and on the other hand I do want to
call this out guys get off your butts
and help around the house
just help anytime here's an example
anytime you're about to sit down and you
look over and you see your wife not
sitting down you don't sit down yet
don't sit down
I work hard all day shut up don't sit
down
she needs to be shut up don't sit down
before you sit down
ask her
hey is there anything I'm not seeing
anything I can do to help how could I
love you better right now right this
second and she might say sit down and
put your feet up man you've been running
like crazy
and she might say it would mean the
world to me if you could just go grab
the hamper out of such and such kid's
room
what a gift
so I want every every wife every husband
every couple listening to this this talk
about division of labor I want you all
to sit down and say okay where do you
feel like I don't show up for you and
this is man this this I'm not
genderizing this it could be any of you
where am I not showing up for you when
it comes to
the division of labor in the household
and for those things that come up like I
do help around like the kitchen oh once
a week well that's uh that's all that
needs to be cleaned okay now we have not
a division of labor issue but a what
does labor look like an Excellence issue
a I feel safe I Feel clean I feel gross
I feel not enough
um whatever that looks like
and it may be that the kitchen needs to
be this clean in case somebody comes
over and they're going to judge you
husband or wife by the cleanliness of
your kitchen standards
and so if it's not up to that that
keeping up with the Joneses someone may
come over and judge me so I'm gonna
blame him or blame her for not living up
to this imaginary stand you see how we
get into this weird dance
so all that said
sit on and help each other out the
second one finances
I think money finances is less about
money and more about a couple of things
number one control
whoever controls the money controls the
house
and it can be controlled in one of two
ways the very abusive
with significant correlation to physical
abuse the guy and yes I'm over
genderizing this when you don't spend
money without me you don't go to store
by yourself you don't do any like
there's that kind of control I run the
money around here and that women can run
the money like I I am the person in
charge of the money
I'll give you an allowance
so I hear that or hey let me check with
my wife see if I can buy that sh man
that means y'all haven't talked so that
there's that kind of control
there's also control I just spend
whatever I want whenever I want
I buy whatever you can't tell me what I
can there's that control too which is
madness
also finances is about worth
in our culture when you ask the question
what is he worth what is she worth we
Define that not by relationships and not
by who she who they're loved and who who
they love and who love them
we answer the question what are you
worth with a number which is a tragedy
it's a cultural tragedy
but that's what we do and if my number
is low it's easy to begin to feel like
not pulling his weight he's not worth
much I'm married to a loser and that
goes both ways you know both genders all
over the place
and
the third one
money is a really good indicator you can
look at how much you make right now and
what your career trajectory is and you
can just push out 30 or 40 years and say
okay this is about what our life's gonna
look like
and most of us don't like to live in
that reality
so money tells you who you are and what
you find valuable how you spend money
and so
couples need to sit down and say hey
where are we going
what do we find valuable together in
this life we've chosen to make together
it never ceases to amaze me as long as I
live
people will create humans together
they'll share DNA but they won't share a
checking account
this my money this is his money this is
her money
I can't think of other than just
outright abuse and infidelity I can't
think of something that's more divisive
in a marriage
if you have to protect your own money
you shouldn't get married
because you're not all in you're mostly
in
and mostly it doesn't work in marriage
all right that can be a whole
conversation real quick raising children
um I want to do it like this or you want
to do it like that or my mom did it like
this or this is how I was raid kids are
the parent new parent scorecard it's the
report card for parents in the 21st
century
everyone's got steps and tips and tricks
instead of focusing on your relationship
with each other and focusing on your
relationship with the kids
good
that's a whole other conversation
but there's something about saying okay
when this kid is 25.
what do we want for this our child
and I would start that conversation I
would number one
I want my kid to want to come home
why do I start there instead of I want
my kid to be successful my kid to be a
Fortune 500 CEO I want my my kid to be
married well because everything
everything for a child is rooted in
the attachment relationship with their
parents
everything so whenever I think about my
son or I think about my daughter I I
push out to the age they're 25 and I
hope wherever they are married kids
single in the military a roofer
getting a postdoc at Stanford whatever
I number one first and foremost want
them to know oh dude there's a safe
place I can always go
there's two people that are rooting for
me
no matter what
Brazen kids about relationship fourth
one is sex you know we talk about this
all the time on this show sex means
everything in our culture all of it all
at once it's the most wild twist of fate
but here we are
um and uh um
I'll I'll blow past that one because we
talked about that a lot here I want to
touch on this because it's important
women are more likely to report problems
than men
as Esther perel is reported as women
have entered the workforce and earned
economic independence divorces have
spiked
because women no longer have to take
abusive bum husbands they can just leave
and
throughout history that has not been
possible
and now you see it happening all over
the world
women are demanding more and I want
everyone to hear this this is good for
everybody
and I love what Terence real says the
world of relationships has changed
radically it's exploded women have been
lied to that they're all they need
you can do this all by yourself now now
that you are economically independent
you need nobody
their careers and Independence will
complete them and save them this isn't
true this is bearing itself out in the
mental health literature and Men
just want to go back to the way things
used to be if we can just get these
roles back to where they used to be
then everything will be fine this is
foolish and stupid it's also not going
to happen
what has to happen is a total rethinking
of marriage and relationships and
attachment and connection this is why I
do this show is to paint a new picture
of what life can look like when two
people get on the same page and say
let's ride or die and let's do this
thing right and we don't have we don't
have a road map because this isn't how
our parents did it it's not how their
parents did it before them
Terence real says women are unhappy in
their marriages because they want men to
be more related
more relatable than most men know how to
be and men are unhappy in their
marriages because their women seem so
unhappy with them
I think that's so powerful
women want a co-earner and a
co-um parent razor and a CO
partner and a and a somebody to share
their dreams with us someone to talk
with and someone to be romantic with and
most men don't have all those skills
that's all the other skills
and men just want to know why their
wives don't like them
why don't you like me
and I don't know how to ask that
question so I covered up with beer and
football games and loudness and whatever
other thing I decide I'm gonna crank out
into the world
so let's create a world where men can
say hey I feel this thing
and I'm gonna go do the next right thing
and women can say I feel this thing and
then I'm gonna go to the next right
thing and we're gonna do the next right
thing together
and a quick Buzz through these things
the 10 sources of conflict Partners
condescending
possessive jealous or dependent
neglecting rejecting unreliable abusive
Unfaithful and considerate
um physically self-absorbed a great sign
of immaturity there Moody emotionally
unstable you spray your feelings all
over the place sexually withholding or
rejecting
quick to sexualize others you're always
talking about how hot everybody else is
some of you are listening to this and
you're like I don't know what to do
here's a great place to start
if you're like oh crap that's me that's
me that's me great place to start
get a babysitter
take your significant other out
male or female I don't care
and start the conversation like this
I'm sorry
I made you a project
a major my dad
I was trying to be your mom
I thought complaining and nagging or
avoiding and not participating
was the way I could get through life and
I don't want that anymore
I want you and I to build something
bigger and greater and I'm going first
I'm sorry
I don't know how we get to where we're
going from here but I'm committed to
ride if you are let's do something
different let's create a life worth
living let's create a life where we
laugh a lot and it's not very anxious
and it is a life of Joy because it's
going to be hard so let's agree to
do the hard stuff together and to create
a life it's not anxious and that's fun
while we can
start there start there
few few conversations are made worse by
starting with the words I'm sorry
hmm
let's minimize conflict if we can
we all need a little less conflict